This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人克尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）带来的《艰难一课》（Learn the Hardway）。这个节目聚焦于黑男性的生活经历，进行一些在其他地方绝对无法坦诚交流的真实对话，但在这里，你是在和一位知悉其道的持证专业人士对话。有多少男人披着盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力就必须这么做，请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方，
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
收听《艰难一课》。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立弹性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。名字叫《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个劣迹斑斑的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想蒙混过关。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
请在iHeartradio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》。在《回顾过去》（The Look Back at it）播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to another episode. It is so great to have you here, new listeners, old listeners, I am so powerful.
和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），在这个播客中，我们将探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。欢迎回到节目。欢迎收听新的一期节目。很高兴能邀请到大家，新听众、老听众，我真的超级
pumped for today's episode because we have a fantastic, amazing guest joining us to talk about this week's topic. Hi, Sydney. Hi, Gemma. How are you? I'm amazing. How are you? I'm so good. Thank you for agreeing to come on board. It's my pleasure. I feel like we've been wanting to do this for a while, right? A long time. Yeah. Yeah. I might just give you a bit more of an introduction. Please. So, because I feel like we're already just having a chit chat away. Yeah. So Sydney is one of my, probably one my closest, closest friends, but you didn't know that. Same. No, no, same. It's feeling is reciprocated.
为今天的节目感到兴奋，因为我们有一位非常棒、非常了不起的嘉宾加入我们，来聊聊本周的话题。嗨，悉尼。嗨，杰玛。你好吗？我好极了。你呢？我也很好。谢谢你答应来参加。这是我的荣幸。我觉得我们好像一直想这么做来着，对吧？好久了。是啊。是啊。我可能需要再给你做个简单的介绍。请吧。因为我觉得我们已经开始闲聊了。对。所以悉尼是我的，可能是我最亲密、最亲密的朋友之一，但你不知道这个。我也是。不，不，我也是。这种感觉是相互的。
It's mutual. Yeah. Thank God. I hope so. Yeah, yeah, I think we're good. But, Sydney, you are, do you want to explain what you do, how we met before we jump into? Sure.
这是相互的。是的。谢天火。希望如此。对，对，我觉得我们挺好的。不过，悉尼，你想不想在我们深入探讨之前，先解释一下你是做什么的，我们是怎么认识的？当然。
My name is Sydney, like the city. Currently, I reside in Melbourne, and I am a tattoo artist, among many other things. I always have different creative pursuits happening, but predominantly I'm a tattoo artist. I run a creative publication called Sweden Sauer that centers around Asian-Australian identities. I also work in consulting a little bit, do some freelance graphic design, and I'm a trained printmaker, which is what I studied. And Gemma and I met in Canberra. How long ago was that? Two years? Three years ago. And we met through, well, we actually met like at a party randomly before the start of COVID
我叫悉尼，就像那个城市一样。我目前住在墨尔本，除了很多其他身份外，我是一名纹身艺术家。我总是有各种各样的创意追求，但主要还是一名纹身艺术家。我经营着一份名为《甜酸》（Sweden Sauer）的创意刊物，主要关注亚裔澳大利亚人的身份认同。我也做一点咨询工作，做一些自由职业的平面设计，而且我受过版画培训，这也是我学专业。我和杰玛是在堪培拉认识的。那是多久以前的事了？两年前？三年前。我们是通过，呃，其实我们在新冠疫情爆发前在一个派对上偶然认识的，
and then COVID happened we didn't stay in touch but Sydney as you could have probably heard and seen is a jack of many trades Jack of many trades Jack of all trades Jack of all trades or not all of them literally well pretty much all of them
然后疫情爆发了，我们就没怎么保持联系。但是悉尼，正如你可能已经听到和看到的那样，是一个全能奇才，全能奇才，全能奇才，全能奇才，或者说也不是全能，字面上讲，基本上全能吧。
has so many different amazing things that she does and through her publication the sweet and sour zine zine scene whatever you want to yeah both work yeah both are correct the publication. She was running a life drawing class, and I went to it. And I, like, went up to you and was like, hi, I don't know if you remember me.
她做了这么多各种各样了不起的事情，通过她的刊物——《甜酸》杂志（zine），Zine圈，随便你怎么称呼，两个都可以，两个都对，就是那个出版物。她当时在办一个人体写生班，然后我就去了。然后我，呃，走到你面前说，嗨，我不知道你还记不记得我。
And you were like, oh, hey, like, how are you? And then the rest is really history. And we are here today to talk about something we talk about quite a bit when we're around each other. And, like, not in the way that we're like, oh, like, boys, boys, boys. Yeah. Ew, no. No, I don't think it is like that. And even if it was, like, who gives a fun?
然后你说，哦，嗨，最近怎么样？然后剩下的就不用多说了。我们今天来到这里，是要聊聊一些我们在一起时经常讨论的事情。而且，不是那种“哦，天哪，男生，男生，男生”的那种。对。噫，才不呢。不，我觉得才不是那样呢。就算真的是这样，谁他妈在乎啊？
I love boys. And I hate them. And that's what this episode is about. Literally. It's about the nuances of hating and loving the opposite gender for romantic purposes. But what we really want to talk about is, like, a lot of things, why we can really struggle with dating in our 20s, why we fall in love with the wrong people, why we date the wrong people, how we attract these, like, the same kind of individuals.
我喜欢男生。我也恨他们。这就是本期节目的主题。真的。这就是关于出于恋爱目的去恨和爱异性的微妙之处。但我们真正想聊的是很多事情，比如为什么我们在20多岁时会在约会中苦苦挣扎，为什么我们会爱上错的人，为什么我们会和错的人约会，我们是如何吸引到这些，呃，同一类人的。
I feel like it's something that a lot of us have to learn in our 20s. Maybe you don't. Maybe you found your person and that's it. And congratulations, if that's you. But for most of us, I would say you find the people that you truly love and the type of person you truly love through a lot of trial and error. Would you agree? Yes. Yes. And it's hard and it's exhausting. Yeah. But I think it's always worth it. Yeah. I would say so. It hasn't, to be honest, hasn't been worth it for me so far. well I think you'll reflect back on that in five or ten years and realize that all the shitty things that have happened to you in your dating life have made it worth have made you know it worthwhile worthwhile yeah even this year actually I think that I was like dating someone at the end of last year and the amount of like growth that came out of that was ridiculous
我觉得这是我们大多数人在20多岁时都必须要去学习的东西。也许你不用。也许你找到了你的真命天子，那就这样吧。如果是这样，恭喜你。但对于我们大多数人来说，我想说，你是通过大量的试错，才找到你真正深爱的人以及你真正喜欢的那种类型的。你同意吗？是的。是的。这很难，而且很累。是的。但我认为这总是值得的。是的。我会这么说。说实话，对我来说到目前为止还不值得。嗯，我觉得你过个五十年后回过头来看，就会发现你在约会生活中经历的所有那些烂事其实都是值得的，让你明白了……明白了，是的。甚至就在今年，实际上，我觉得我去年年底的时候跟一个人约会过，那之后带来的成长简直离谱。
like he like completely broke my heart and it was like terrible yeah sometime yeah and then I was like like I just like completely became a different person like with all like I think it left me feeling so insecure I had like the lowest self-esteem I think I've ever had and I couldn't like jump into a new relationship to fix it so I had to do it all myself and now like the person I was 12 months ago I don't know I don't think I don't think much of her exists anymore what about you to learn any lessons from this year you've had quite a few lessons I feel like it's been a busy year for you in terms of dating. Yeah.
就像他，完全击碎了我的心，感觉太糟糕了，有时，是的，然后我就像，完全变成了另一个人，带着所有的，我觉得这让我感到无比没有安全感，我的自尊心跌到了我觉得有生以来的最低谷，我没办法通过马上开始一段新恋情来修复它，所以我必须全靠自己走出来。现在，12个月前的那个我，我不觉得，我不觉得她身上还剩下多少了。你呢？今年吸取到什么教训了吗？你好像经历了不少教训，我觉得对你来说今年在约会方面是个忙碌的一年。是的。
Wait, don't they say that your cells, like, not regenerate, but like, they die and then they regenerate every 12 months or something like that? So literally the person you were 12 years ago physically doesn't exist anymore, which I think is an interesting metaphor for what you just said. Oh, my God, yeah. But it's so funny because, like, even though those cells don't still exist, right, like, all those memories still do? Yeah.
等等，他们不是说你的细胞，不是说它们不再生，而是说每隔12个月左右它们就会死掉然后再生吗？所以字面意思上，12年前身体上的那个你其实已经不复存在了，我觉得这对于你刚才说的话是个很有意思的比喻。天哪，对啊。但这太好笑了，因为，即便那些细胞已经不在了，对吧，但所有的那些记忆依然存在？对。
You can't get rid of that. Yeah, I'm like, how? Whoa. Whoa. We need to do some real serious science on this episode. Because I do not understand that. Yeah, if the cells that hold those memories don't exist, then how do those memories still exist?
你摆脱不掉这个。是的，我就想，怎么会？哇。哇。我们需要对这个话题做点真正严肃的科学研究。因为我真的无法理解这一点。对，如果保存这些记忆的细胞都不存在了，那这些记忆又是怎么依然存在的？
It's fucking the demon. The demon is at work in our mind. Damn. Well, like, that is actually such a good point. I think it's also the thing with blood, right? Like, all your blood? I guess it's still the cells. Yeah.
简直见鬼了。恶魔在我们的脑子里搞鬼。可不是嘛。不过，这确实是一个很好的观点。我觉得这也跟血液有关，对吧？就像你所有的血？我猜还是细胞。
Actually, I do know the answer to this. Your neurons, your synapses, they actually, the cells within them might regenerate, but you can never have more neurons than you were born with. That's true. Which is why, like, doing hardcore, like, drugs or, like, when, if someone is an alcoholic, can be so, especially in their infancy or not infancy, but, like, in their early teens or late teens, can be so damaging because you never get more neurons than you're born with, which is why, I guess, like, our memory is staying.
其实，我知道这个问题的答案。你的神经元，你的突触，它们实际上，里面的细胞可能会再生，但你拥有的神经元数量永远不会超过你出生时的数量。确实如此。这就是为什么，比如吸食强力毒品，或者，如果有人酗酒，会带来如此大的伤害，尤其是在他们的幼儿时期，或者不是幼儿时期，而是在十几岁出头或快成年的时候，会具有极大的破坏性，因为你永远无法获得比出生时更多的神经元，这就是为什么，我猜，我们的记忆会保持得如此
so permanent because either you like completely damage your brain and you get amnesia and then you can forget about whatever it is that haunts you or you don't and you're rough anyhow there's the science behind it I feel like that was kind of like a patchwork
永久，因为要么你彻底毁了自己的大脑然后得了失忆症，这样你就能忘掉那些纠缠你的事情，要么你就没有，然后你就只能硬扛。不管怎样，这就是背后的科学原理。我觉得这解释得有点像东拼西凑的。
explanation yeah yeah we got there though yeah we did so lessons any 2023 lessons oh man I should have rid the list I have so many like TikTok saved or it's like things I wish I knew about dating in my 20s and things I learned from dating this year. And I have all my favorite ones.
对，对，不过我们确实解释通了。是的，那么教训呢？2023年的教训？天哪，我应该列个清单的。我存了好多TikTok，上面写着“我希望自己在20多岁约会时就知道的那些事”以及“我从今年的约会中学到的东西”。我把我最喜欢的好多都存了。
I should have written down a list of my favorite ones. Yeah. Can you remember when it's like particularly like? Yeah. I think, um, I think one thing that's really stuck out. Okay, two things really stick out to me when you ask me that question. Two kind of statements. The first one we've heard this a million times.
我本来应该把我最喜欢的那些列个清单的。对。你还能记起有什么特别的吗？对。我觉得，嗯，我觉得有一件事真的很突出。好吧，两件事在我被问到这个问题时真的很突出。两种类似说法的观点。第一种，我们听过无数遍了。
And I think we all try and convince ourselves to believe it, but a lot of us don't. If, if he wanted to, he would. And the second statement is, um, why are we having relationship problems and people were not in a relationship with? And I feel like both of those things really encapsulate my my dating life of 2020, which is
而且我想我们都试图说服自己去相信它，但很多人其实并没有真正做到。如果他想的话，他就会去做。第二种说法是，嗯，为什么我们要跟那些甚至没有跟我们确立恋爱关系的人一起承担恋爱中的问题？我觉得这两件事完美概括了我在2020年的约会生活，这
kind of sad when those two statements aren't exactly positive, but I really, yeah, I really think those accurately reflect my life. I think through all, I've dated a lot of men in 2020, like a lot. 2020. My bad. I've dated a lot of men in 2022 and in 20, no, 2020
其实挺可悲的，当这两句话其实并不是那么积极正面的时候，但我真的，是的，我真的觉得它们准确地反映了我的生活。我觉得经历了所有这些，我在2022年约会了很多男人，真的很多。2020。我的错。我在2022年约会了很多男人。而且我觉得很多次我都愿意给他们留出余地。我愿意给他们第二次机会。而且我真的相信这些男人里有很多可能就是那个对的人，他们其实非常非常在乎我，甚至爱我。
I was in a relationship, so I didn't date a lot of men. Try that again. Hopefully. I dated a lot of men in 2022. And I think so many times I was willing to give them the benefit of the doubt. I was willing to give them a second chance. And I really believed that a lot of these men maybe were the one and that they really, really cared for me and loved me even.
我看到了他们最好的一面。我一次次给他们第二次机会，觉得他们不是，不是，不是，我不是想让他们改变。而是我或许抱有一种希望，希望他们能意识到，你知道的，我其实是个很好的人，而且他们也想跟我在一起。他们也告诉过我他们想要这些，诸如此类的。但我觉得认真地说，如果他想的话，他就会去做。我觉得人们会说自己还没准备好恋爱。但如果你真的爱一个人、珍视一个人，并且想跟这个人在一起，
And I saw the best in them. And I kept giving them second chances and thinking that they were not not, not, I didn't want them to change. but perhaps I held on to the hope that they would realize that, you know, I was a really good person and they wanted to be, you know, have something with me. And they told me they wanted it and whatever. But I think seriously, if he wanted to, he would. I think people say they're not ready for a relationship. But if you really do love someone and value someone and you want to be in a relationship with them,
无论如何你都会促成这段关系。无论如何。我完全同意这种说法。就是，如果他们想的话，他们就会去做。对。我确实看到过另一种针对这句名言的说法，大意是如果他们心知肚明，那他们就该有所行动。就像如果他们知道你的期望，
you'll make it work no matter what. No matter. I completely agree with that statement. Like, if they wanted to, they would. Yeah. I did see this, like, turn on it that was like, if they know, then they should. It's like if they know what you expect,
那他们就应该给出回应。如果他们不知道，那他们绝对就不是对的人。但我真心相信这一点，因为我想想自己对待约会的态度，当我真正深爱一个人时，我愿意为他们付出一切。付出一切，是的。
then they should reciprocate it. And if they don't, well, then they're definitely not the right person. But I honestly believe this, because I think about my own perspective towards dating, when I really care about someone, like, I am willing to give them everything. Everything, yeah.
而且可能超出了我所能给予的，甚至超过了他们作为一个男生理应从我这里得到的。我的人生中也有过这样的时刻，当时我想：我才不要谈恋爱。我完全没有这种心态。然后我遇到了某个人，他们就是那个对的人，结果我跟他们谈了大概两年的恋爱。
And probably more than I can give, more than they probably deserve from me as well. And there have been times in my life when I've been like, I do not want a relationship. I am so not in the mindset. And then I meet someone and they are the right person and I end up dating them for like two years.
是的，开始的时候确实会有那么一些时刻，我会觉得，哦，我不知道，我不知道。但不是为了我自己的利益，而是为了他们的利益，因为我不想伤害他们。当你真的能和某个人感受到化学反应，并且拥有这种直觉时，真的没有任何理由去说你还没准备好承兑承诺。不，没有什么能阻止你。
And yeah, there is those times at the beginning where I'm like, oh, I don't know, I don't know. But not for their, like, not for my sake, for their sake because I don't want to hurt them. When you really, like, can feel chemistry with someone and you have that intuition, like, there really is no reason why you shouldn't be ready for commitment. No, nothing will stop you.
是的。是的。其实这是一个很好的教训。而且我也只是觉得，随着我约会的男人越来越多，我学到了更多，我开始心想：我真的想拖着你、逼着你、让你踢打尖叫着跟我谈恋爱吗？对，对。或者像是在哀求你……是的，或者试着说服你、劝导你，或者做一些事情来让你，你知道的，明白你其实是想跟我谈恋爱。是的。
Yeah. Yeah. It's a good lesson, actually. And I also just think it's something that I've learned more, the more men I've dated, where I'm like, do I really want to be dragging you, kicking and screaming into a relationship with me? Yeah, yeah. Or like begging you for. Yeah, or try and convince you or persuade you or do things to make you, you know, understand that you do want a relationship with me. Yeah.
不，你应该一眼就能明白。对。而且这也只是在提醒你，你知道吗？你的真命天子可能还在外面等着呢。如果那个人不是我，嗯，我不认为爱情里应该包含这么多的纠结和这么多的艰难。对。不，我觉得我从今年学到的另一个教训是，事情其实非常非黑即白。
No, you should just know. Yeah. And it's also just like, you know what? Your person's probably out there. And if it's not me, well, I don't think that love should be made up of so much tension and so much difficulty. Yeah. No, I think another lesson I learned from this year is that things are really quite black and white.
比如，我觉得我为很多人找了借口。就像，你知道的，我会看着某个人然后心想：哦，如果他们生活里没有遇到这些破事的话，他们其实是愿意跟我谈恋爱的。而且他们确实非常非常爱我、在乎我，也想跟我谈恋爱，但现在正发生着这些事。也许等事情过去之后他们就会变了，或者，你知道的，这事会发生，那事会解决。不，这真的很非黑即白。如果他们想的话，他们就会去做。如果他们现在就想要我，他们就会跟我在一起。对。
Like, I think I made up excuses for lots of people. Like, you know, I'd see someone and be like, oh, they would be in a relationship with me if they didn't have this going on in their life. And they do really, really love me and care for me and want to be in a relationship with me, but this is happening. And maybe after that happens, they'll be different or, you know, this will happen and that'll happen. No, it's really black and white. If they wanted to, they would. If they wanted me right now, they would be with me. Yeah.
而且他们才不会编造那些借口。好吧，我想到了那个例子，比如你过去两个月经历的事情，对吧，跟那个人之间。嗯。我们现在聊这个可以吗？可以，可以，可以。我想知道他会不会听这本书。不。
And they wouldn't make up those excuses. Well, I think about the example, like what you went through in the last two months, right, with that person. Mm-hmm. And are we okay to talk about this? Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I wonder if he'll listen to the book. No.
我想知道他会不会听。也许吧。不过，没关系。我不在乎。好吧，如果你正在听的话，你可真是把这手好牌打得稀烂。对。贱人。这句话从你嘴里说出来听着太不自然了。
I wonder if you will. Maybe. But, yeah, it's fine. I don't care. Well, if you're listening, you really fumbled the fucking bag. Yeah. Bitch. Like, that felt so unnatural coming out of your mouth.
自然还是不自然，或者很不自然？很不自然。不过，他确实是。还记得你打电话给我，然后我说：那个男的刚刚遭遇了他人生中最惨的一次滑铁卢。因为我觉得这是，哦，他其实知道的。一条圣诞祝福。
Natural or unnatural or unnatural? Unnatural. Well, he did. He did. Remember you called me and I was like, that man just had the biggest L of his life. Because I think this is, oh, he does actually know it. A little Christmas message.
我们一眼就能看穿那点小心思。我甚至还发了一个关于那个的TikTok给你。发圣诞祝福。对。你知道吗？他真的干了。而且这也是我意识到更多的一点，我也希望，我觉得你也意识到了，
We all see right through that. There was literally a TikTok I sent you about that. Sending the Christmas message. Yeah. And you know what? He really did. And it's something that I've realized more and I hope, I think you've realized this as well.
当你越成熟，对自己的自信心越强，并且看到了自己的价值时，你就会越觉得：哇，完全是你的损失。是的，完全是。大多数对我们最差的男人，往往都是那些真正一无所有的人。就是，没什么本事。我前几天还在想这个。我当时在想那些曾经伤过我心的人。然后我心想：他们当中没有一个人取得了任何值得我尊重的东西。特别是跟你相比。
the more you mature and grow confident in yourself and like see your value, the more you're like, wow, totally your loss. Yeah, completely. Most of the men who treat us the worst are those who really have nothing going for them. Like, not much. Like, I was thinking about this the other day. I was like looking at the splattering of people that have broken my heart. And I was like, not one of them has accomplished anything that I could respect. especially compared to you.
对。他们，哦，我不知道这……我觉得，我觉得你让我感觉怪怪的。不。
Yeah. They, oh, I don't know if that. I think, I think, that you make me feel weird. No.
抛开比较不谈，对吧，如果不带有相对的视角，而是绝对的视角。他们没有一个人，我喜欢他们，他们毫无野心。
Without the comparison, right, if it's just not to be like relative about it, but like absolute. None of them, I like, they had no ambitions.
如果不作比较的话，对吧，如果不是相对而言，而是绝对来看。他们当中没有一个——我喜欢，他们毫无野心。
They had no dreams. Most of them didn't even have, like, a job. They didn't have anything they were passionate about. And even if they did, like,
他们没有梦想。他们大多数人甚至连工作都没有，没有什么真正热爱的东西。即使有，
they didn't take it very seriously. They weren't like self-motivated, self-starters, like none of it. So what are you? did you see in them? I don't know. I think I saw a project, to be honest. Or also I just saw what they could give me, which was like, I want to be loved. And I think it's a massive thing of mine where it's like I'm very much willing to actually go against what I truly believe in some
他们也不是很认真。他们不是那种自我驱动、积极主动的人，完全不是。那你到底在他们身上看到了什么？我不知道。老实说，我觉得我看到的是一个项目。或者我也只是看到了他们能给我的东西，那就是渴望被爱。我觉得这对我来说是一件大事，为了得到关爱和浪漫，我非常愿意违背自己真正坚守的某些
ways to receive affection and to receive romance. It's something I had to unlearn this year. And I did. I like very actively was like, I can see the times in the past in which I have actually undermined my own moral compass. I've gone against my values because I was so desperate for this person's admiration and for their love. And the result has been me feeling like completely distanced from my true self. And why, for what? For what reason?
原则。这是我今年不得不戒掉的一点。而且我确实做到了。我非常积极地意识到，在过去的一些时刻里，我实际上是在破坏自己的道德罗盘。我违背了自己的价值观，因为我太渴望得到这个人的赞赏和爱了。结果就是我感到自己与真实的自我完全疏离了。为什么，为了什么？究竟是为什么？
Like I think about that guy I dated at the end of last year. Oh my God. Like I did, I was like, I lost friends because I chose to be with him. And it's like what you said, stop having relationship problems with people you're not in a relationship with. We weren't even like exclusive. And I still was willing to make those sacrifices. It's not his fault. Definitely not.
就像我想起去年年底约会的那个人。天哪。我甚至为了和他在一起而失去了朋友。就像你说的，别和那些根本不是你恋人的人产生感情问题。我们甚至都不是专属关系。但我仍然愿意做出那些牺牲。这绝对不是他的错。
It's like all on me for not recognizing that for myself soon enough. I think like another thing that I really want to talk about is like, why do you think we do date the wrong people and fall in love with the wrong people? Given that we have all of that knowledge. Like we are obviously both quite successful. starting women who have a lot of people who love us and who create positive impact. Like you literally put art on people's bodies that they're going to have for the rest of their lives. How great.
这完全怪我自己没有早点认清这一点。我觉得我还想讨论的另一件事是，为什么我们认为我们会和错的人约会，爱上错的人？明明我们都懂这些道理。显然我们都是相当成功的、起步很好的女性，身边有很多人爱我们，也能创造积极的影响。就像你亲手把艺术纹在人们的皮肤上，让他们终生相伴。这多棒啊。
Like that is like almost, that is so profound to me when you, every time I like see you at work. I feel so honored to be able to do that. Yeah. It's incredible. And we know all this about ourselves, right? Like we know that sometimes we just crave affection. We look past the red flags. that as I think successful women sometimes we settle a little bit because we worry that someone
这简直，每次我在工作看到你的时候，我都觉得这太深刻了。我为能做这件事感到无比荣幸。是的。太不可思议了。我们对自己的这些情况都很清楚，对吧？比如我们知道有时我们只是渴望关爱。我们会忽略那些危险信号，因为我觉得作为成功的女性，有时我们会将就，因为我们担心有人
won't ever want this kind of like I don't know not ever want it but like we'll feel intimidated or it's like when you when you're forced to be strong all the time sometimes you just want the soft yeah yeah yeah sometimes you just want the gooniness and like someone just really giving you a cuddle and like caring about you so why do you think it is that we have historically chosen to date the wrong people? I honestly, I don't know. Maybe it comes maybe it comes from, I think
永远不会想要这种——我不知道，也不是永远不想要，而是会感到害怕，或者就像当你被迫总是表现得很坚强时，有时你只是想要温柔。对，对，有时你只是想要那种傻乎乎的温存，有人真正给你一个拥抱并在乎你。所以你觉得为什么我们过去总是选择和错的人约会呢？说实话，我不知道。也许这来自于，我觉得
I have a lot of insecurities. I think they probably stem from things I went through as a child and maybe the way my parents raised me, but I'm like, what did I read the other day? I have, like I,
我有很多不安全感。我觉得它们可能源于我童年的经历，或者我父母抚养我的方式，但我想，我前几天都读到了什么？我有，就像我，
someone sent me, Manu sent me this TikTok and it was like, um, some of you, back what was, I can't remember. Yeah. Um, yeah,
有人发给我，Manu发给我的这个TikTok，上面写着，嗯，你们有些人，以前是什么，我记不清了。对，嗯，对，
I think, I think, I think, I, even though I think logically, I know I'm a successful, you know, business woman,
我觉得，我觉得，我觉得，我，尽管从逻辑上讲我知道自己是一个成功的、你知道的、女商人，
I'm, I think I'm a relatively attractive. Oh, gorgeous. Thank you. Logically, I feel like I shouldn't have as many insecurities that I do have.
我，我觉得自己相对有吸引力。哦，美极了。谢谢。从逻辑上讲，我觉得自己不该有这么多的不安全感。
Like, I am so incredibly insecure. and I think maybe that plays a big part in how I date because I feel so insecure. Maybe I don't think that I deserve or have the capacity to be with somebody who is at my level who like I would really want to date and maybe I'm settling because I just don't believe I could find anybody better because I am so insecure. Wow. That's sad.
天哪，我是如此缺乏安全感。我想这可能在我的约会方式中起到了很大的作用，因为我感到太没有安全感了。也许我认为自己不配或者没有能力和那些与我势均力敌、我真正想约会的人在一起，也许我将就只是因为我深信自己找不到更好的人，因为我太没有安全感了。哇。这太令人难过了。
It is sad, but I think it makes sense, right? I saw, I read this article the other day and it was like a lot of the time, the reason why we get like the ick from people who like us too much is because we believe so deeply that we are not deserving of that love that we push them away, which is a big thing, right? Totally. You're like, I also, I think similarly, like in a very similar vein, as people who, you know, work really hard and have pretty big dreams that we know are going to require a lot of agency. We often see it as the case of like when I have to work harder for something, it's more valuable. Yeah. I think about this all the time. Yeah.
这确实令人难过，但我觉得这也说得通，对吧？我前几天看到一篇文章，上面说很多时候，我们对那些太喜欢我们的人产生反感的原因，是因为我们深深地觉得自己不配得到那份爱，所以我们把他们推开，这是一件大事，对吧？完全赞同。你就会想，我也觉得，类似地，在某种非常相似的层面上，对于那些努力工作、拥有巨大梦想、知道这需要大量自主权的人来说。我们经常发现这种情况：当我必须为某事付出更多努力时，它就更有价值。是的。我一直都在想这个。是的。
So it's like, okay, I think the way I was raised was like, if it's easy, then everyone can do it. And you don't want the thing that everyone has. Like you want to be, you know, you want to do something different and you want to really be good at something different and be able to touch people's lives in a way that like it's not everyone can do that. and you have to work really hard. So now it's like been ingrained to me. It's like, well, if something is easy, it's not worth having. Like in every other facet of our lives, we have to work really hard and put in a lot of effort. So that mentality then bleeds into our dating life.
所以这就好比，我觉得我受到的教育是，如果事情很容易，那么每个人都能做到。而你不会想要那种人人都有的东西。你想成为，你知道的，你想做点不一样的事情，想真正擅长一些与众不同的事，并以一种不是每个人都能做到的方式去触动别人的生活，而这需要你付出巨大的努力。所以现在这种观念已经根深蒂固地印在我的脑海里。这就好比，如果某件事很简单，那就不值得拥有。就像在我们生活的方方面面，我们都必须非常努力并付出大量心血。所以这种心态自然就渗透到了我们的约会生活中。
When we have someone who's there who, like, is really obsessed with us, who really likes us, we're like, oh, this seems a little bit too good to be true. And I'm not used to getting something like this for free. And you push it away. You push it away. And then when there's someone that you have to work, when they, you know,
当身边出现一个真正对我们痴迷、真正喜欢我们的人时，我们会想，哦，这看起来有点好得不真实了。我不习惯白白得到这样的东西。于是你把它推开。你把它推开。然后当出现一个需要你付出努力的人，当他们，你知道的，
that you don't feel deserving of their love because they push you away and because they play hard to get or because they're quite cold or hostile will never give you what you want, you're like, well, this is what I want because obviously, like,
你觉得自己不配得到他们的爱，因为他们把你推开，因为他们欲擒故纵，或者因为他们相当冷漠、敌对，永远不会给你想要的东西，你就会想，嗯，这正是我想要的，因为很明显，就像，
the best things in life aren't easy. So this, you know, this should be something that I work for. I think that as a mentality that we often have very unconsciously that we don't realize. I've, I honestly think that's a big explanation for some of my dating choices.
生活中的美好事物来之不易。所以这，你知道的，这应该是我努力争取的东西。我觉得这是一种我们经常在潜意识里拥有却没有察觉的心态。老实说，我认为这是我的一些约会选择背后的一个重大解释。
Yeah. It's how we get stuck in these situations because you're like, it's also, sorry, sunk costs as well. Sunk, what? Sunk costs. So it's like, okay, say for example, you buy like a really expensive pair of boots and then they break. You're like, you're not just going to throw them out because you already invested that money in them. Yeah. So you are going to pay that additional $40 to, you know, get the heel fixed.
是的。这就是我们陷入这些困境的原因，因为你会觉得，还有，抱歉，还有沉没成本。沉没，什么？沉没成本。所以这就好比，假设你买了一双非常昂贵的靴子，然后它们坏了。你会觉得，你不会仅仅因为已经投入了这笔钱就把它们扔掉。是的。所以你会额外花40块钱去，你知道的，把鞋跟修好。
And then the zipper breaks, you're not going to throw them out. You are going to pay additional money and it keeps piling up because you've made that initial investment that was so intense that you're like, I don't want to, I've sunk that money into this already. I don't want to lose that initial money, but actually end up spending more money than you probably would have if you just bought a new pair. And that's what it's like with relationships.
然后拉链坏了，你也不会把它们扔掉。你还是会花额外的钱，而且这种投入不断累积，因为你最初的投入太大了，你会想，我不想，我已经把钱投进去了。我不想失去最初的投资，但最终花的钱可能比你直接买双新靴子还要多。这就是恋爱关系的写照。
For example, you're like dating someone, you're like two months in and you're like, fuck, like, I've already told my friends about this guy. I've wasted two months on like getting to know him. I've invested, you know, time and energy and money into going on dates into doing fun things. And now he doesn't want the same thing, but I'm not going to give up because I've already put all of this effort. I've had all these sunk costs in this relationship. So I'm just going to keep throwing my time and energy at it and hoping that it turns around when really it would be better just to dump them right there, then and there. You've lost two months of time.
比如你正在和一个约会两个月左右的人恋爱，然后你会想：操，我都已经跟朋友提起过这个家伙了。我在了解他这件事上浪费了两个月。我在约会和做有趣的事情上投入了时间和精力还有金钱。现在他却不想拥有同样的未来，但我不想放弃，因为我已经付出了这么多的努力。我在这段感情中有了这么多的沉没成本。所以我只想继续把时间和精力投进去，希望事情能有转机——而实际上，当场、立刻甩了他们才是更好的选择。你不过是损失了两个月的时间。
Just move on. Just move on. Yeah, you know, it's not a great situation. Like, it's probably not the outcome that you wanted. but you're actually going to end up losing more if you keep going, and it's very unlikely that you're going to get the outcome that you want. Have you felt that way? Does that, like, make sense?
向前看吧。就往前走吧。对啊，你知道的，这并不是什么好情况。这可能并不是你想要的结局，但如果你继续下去，你最终失去的会更多，而且你几乎不可能得到你想要的结局。你有过这种感觉吗？这听起来……是不是很有道理？
Yeah. Yeah, the way you've explained that makes so much sense. Yeah. It's like gambling. It's like when people gamble, they're like, oh. You know, I've already like put in $2,000 on the pokies. But if I put $10 in, I might be able to win it all back. Yeah.
对。对，你解释得太有道理了。对。这就像赌博。就像人们赌博时会想：哦。你知道的，我已经往老虎机里投了两千块钱了。但如果我再投十块钱，说不定就能把输的全赢回来。对。
That's my theory, really. How do we change that thinking? I think I don't really know I guess it's like a conscious thing you have to be really really like explicit about and very much pay attention to but I think your point before about
这其实就是我的理论。我们该如何改变这种思维方式？我觉得我其实并不太清楚，我猜这就像是一件你必须非常非常明确、需要极度留心的事情，但我觉得你之前提到的
like your childhood that also plays a role in whether or not you're going to I don't want to say like fall but like be vulnerable to these kind of psychological inner workings so like what do you think it was about how your parents raised you
比如你的童年，这也决定了你会不会——我不想用“沦陷”这个词，但可以说是会被这种内心的心理机制所影响。所以你觉得，你父母的教育方式
oh my God we're actually sitting on a couch couch right now, so it's very Freudian. Like, fly back. Tell me about your childhood trauma. It is. Well, I don't really know what a successful relationship looks like, or a successful
天哪，我们现在正坐在一张沙发上，这太弗洛伊德了。就像躺在心理医生的躺椅上一样。跟我说说你的童年创伤吧。确实是。嗯，我其实不知道一段成功的感情是什么样的，或者说一段成功的
marriage, I suppose, rather. My parents got divorced when I was four. My entire extended family, everyone's been through a divorce, everyone's remarried. Nobody in my life really has, I don't think I can't really think of anybody.
婚姻，我觉得更准确地说是婚姻。我四岁时父母就离婚了。我的整个大家庭，每个人都经历过离婚，每个人都重组了家庭。我生活中真的没有人——我甚至想不出有谁
in my, like, close circle of friends and family who is in a successful relationship, a long-term relationship. No, actually, that's not true. I have uncles and aunts who are, like, remarried now. That's pretty far. Yeah. And also, how often do you see your uncles and aunts? Yeah, not that often.
在我关系亲密的朋友和家人圈子里，有谁处于一段成功的长期恋爱关系中。不对，其实也不完全是。我有一些叔叔阿姨现在是重组家庭。那挺远的。对啊，而且你多久才见一次你的叔叔阿姨？对啊，没那么常见。
But my mom's been divorced twice, and now she's fiercely independent and single. My dad only got remarried last year after 20 years of being single. He's just been remarried again. he's been dating his whole life. He seems happy now, but I don't know, like my, my mom, so I felt completely unattractive and undatable and I guess unfuckable when I was, like, since I was a teenager, since, since puberty. Yeah. And I didn't think I deserved anyone's love.
但我妈妈已经离婚两次了，现在她是一个极度独立且单身的女性。我爸爸在单身20年后，直到去年才再次结婚。他刚刚又重新结婚了。他这一辈子都在约会。他现在看起来很开心，但我不知道，比如我妈妈……所以自从我十几岁、进入青春期以来，我就觉得自己完全没有吸引力、没人愿意跟我约会，甚至可以说是毫无性吸引力。对啊。而且我觉得自己不配得到任何人的爱。
I didn't think I was attractive enough to, like, be with anybody. and my mom always told me I was fat and she always criticized my physical appearance a lot to the point where my sister developed an eating disorder. And yeah, she was relatively toxic when I was younger in the way that she raised me. She's good now, I mean, somewhat good. Like we have a pretty good relationship. But I think she didn't give me a lot of physical affection and didn't express her love to me in a tangible way when I was younger, because I mostly grew up with her from when I was 12 years old to
我觉得自己不够有吸引力，不配和任何人在一起。我妈妈总是说我很胖，她总是对我的外表百般挑剔，甚至导致我姐姐患上了饮食失调症。而且，是的，她在我小时候的教育方式上相对来说是比较有毒的。她现在挺好的，我是说，某种程度上挺好的。我们的关系还算不错。但我觉得她没有给我很多身体上的抚摸，在我小时候也没有用切实的方式向我表达爱，因为我大部分时间都是跟她一起长大的，从我12岁一直到
like 21, 22. And she never really touched me or hugged me or told me that she loved me. And so as soon as a, like the first time a man, like, told me that they felt I was hot or wanted to go on a date with me, I clung on to that, like so deeply because then I, then I realized I was lovable and that I could receive love and affection from people. And then I just began to crave that so much because I never got to. that in my childhood from my mother and then I became like a serial dater and I just needed to be with men I remember the first or second year I started
差不多21、22岁。她从来没有真正碰过我、抱过我，也没有对我说过她爱我。所以一旦有一个男人——第一次有男人对我说他觉得我很性感、想跟我约会时，我就紧紧抓住不放，因为那时我才意识到原来我是值得被爱的，我是可以从别人那里得到爱和关怀的。然后我就开始疯狂地渴望这种感觉，因为我在童年时从未从母亲那里得到过。后来我就变成了一个约会狂，我就是需要跟男人在一起。我记得我开始
dating I would just I needed to be with people all the time um and the intimacy that I found through sex and through dating men um yeah like filled that whole yeah metaphorically and physically inside me the whole left yeah that my mother didn't like couldn't fail I do like the sentiment. I think that's why I date shitty men still because it stems all the way back from the way my mother treated me, from me like craving that in men.
约会的头一两年，我只是……我需要一直和别人在一起，呃，我在性爱中以及和男人约会时找到的那种亲密感，是的，它在隐喻上和身体上填补了我内心深处的那个空洞，是的，我母亲未能……无法填补的那个空洞。我确实挺喜欢这种看法的。我觉得这就是为什么我到现在还在和烂男人约会，因为这完全要追溯到我母亲对待我的方式，以及我对男人身上那种关爱的渴望。
Like now I'm more aware of it and I'm more conscious of it and I'm slowly changing and dating with more clarity and more consciously dating. But I do think there's still a part of me that still craves that love and that care that I feel like my mother
就像现在我对这件事有了更多觉察，也更有意识了，我正在慢慢改变，带着更多清晰的认知去约会，更加有意识地去恋爱。但我确实觉得内心深处仍然有一部分，依然渴望着那种爱和关怀——我觉得那是我的母亲
didn't adequately provide me and that I now find in men. Wow. Pretty profound. I think that you're, but I honestly think you're spot on. You reckon? Yeah, I think you deserve a lot of credit as well for moving past that. It's a pretty, like, the wounds from childhood are pretty hard to heal on our own. They are.
没有充分给予我的，而我现在在男人身上寻找的。哇。真是深刻。我觉得你……但我真心觉得你完全说中鸟。是吗？对啊，我觉得你真得很了不起，能够走出来。这真的是……童年的伤痛靠我们自己是很难治愈的。确实很难。
And you've done a pretty, an amazing job. Yeah. Our childhood has such a significant impact on how we approach romantic relationships later in life. whatever it may be like that that instance of your sister is so hard to hear because I'm sure all of us in some way or another have some niggling
而且你做得非常、非常棒。对啊。我们的童年对我们成年后如何看待恋爱关系有着如此深远的影响。无论那是什么，比如你姐姐的那种经历，听起来真的很让人揪心，因为我确信我们所有人多多少少都有一些挥之不去的
little insecurity or mistreatment or trauma from childhood that we just can't seem to shake but still there like I think I had a similar thing to what you were saying where I never felt
童年带来的微小不安、虐待或是创伤，我们怎么也甩不脱，但它们就留在那儿。我觉得我也有过跟你类似的经历，就是我从来不觉得
like anyone found me attractive when I was younger and I never felt particularly, like, lovable. Like, no one really ever showed interest in me at all. Yeah. Compared to all the other girls, because I was, like, pretty nerdy, and I kind of, like, stuck to myself a little bit.
当我小的时候有人会觉得我有吸引力，我也从来不觉得自己特别讨人喜欢。就像，从来没有人真正对我有过兴趣。对啊。跟其他女孩比起来，因为我挺书呆子的，然后我有点……比较孤僻。
And I was, like, yeah, I was a bit of a nerd. And I didn't, like, go out and party or do anything like that. Like, I wanted to read and make art and, like, you know, go to book club and play basketball. Like, I was a loser. But I love that. I love that I was a loser. Because look at how it's turned out, right? Like, I moved away from...
而且我，对啊，我有点像个书呆子。我不会出去派对或者做那些事。我想看书、搞艺术，然后，你知道的，去读书俱乐部、打篮球。我简直是个失败者。但我喜欢这样。我喜欢自己曾是个失败者。因为你看现在结果多好，对吧？比如我
home when I was 18 and like completely created a new life for myself that I love. But that early experience where everyone else around you is dating, it's having like their first sexual experiences, is like having these early romantic experiences. When you feel like you're missing out on those, you get you, you get older and suddenly you're like, okay, I want that now. And you begin to collect. because it's like every time you receive that affection that you never got in those early like teen years, those formative teen years, it feels initially like it's healing you. Like it's giving you the thing that you've always wanted.
18岁就离家独立了，完全为自己创造了一种我热爱的生活。但那种早期的经历——当周围所有人都在约会、在经历他们的第一次性体验、在经历这些早期的浪漫体验时——当你觉得自己错过了这些，当你长大后，突然之间你就会想：好吧，我现在要得到它。然后你开始不断索取，
Yeah, it's intense, right? I'm sure you, did you find that like that first? Yeah, yeah. And I'm sure it didn't mean as much to the man showing that, you know, to me, it felt it was much more important to me than it was to him. But yeah, it probably didn't mean anything, but to me it meant everything. and then they clung onto that so much more. And every time someone, a new person shows you that, it just, it kind of,
因为这就像是，每次你收到那些你在年少时、在性格形成的那些青春期里从未得到过的关爱时，最初的感觉就像是在治愈你。就像它在给你你一直想要的东西一样。
not so much reaffirms, but it, I don't know, it, like, pushes aside that belief that you have. Like, I'm not lovable. And every time, like, someone else shows you that you are, someone else shows you that they are attracted to, that they want to have sex with you, that want to date you. Yeah.
与其说是重申，倒不如说它，我不知道，它就像是，把那种你心里的信念给推开了一样。比如，我不招人喜欢。而每次，比如，当别人向你证明你是时，别人向你证明他们对你感兴趣，他们想和你发生性关系，想和你约会。是的。
It just, like, pushes that belief further and further away. But it actually never really addresses it. No, it's like, it's a band-aid. It's kind of a band-aid solution. Yeah. makes you more reliant on them as well, which then makes the problem, I guess, kind of worse. Yeah, absolutely. Because you're like, shit, I didn't actually work on my self-esteem in other ways. I just used this external validation to distract me from that.
这只会让那种信念离你越来越远。但它其实从来没有真正解决过这个问题。不，这就像是个创可贴。这有点像权宜之计。是的，这也让你更加依赖他们，我觉得这反而让问题变得更糟了。是的，绝对是。因为你会觉得，靠，我其实并没有在其他方面努力提升自信。我只是利用这种外部认可来分散注意力。
And to put a temporary band-aid over this, like, very big wound that is going to actually impact me not only just in my dating life, but everywhere else as well. That's definitely something I found. And then I was like, went through, I remember in like my second year of uni, I was just like, went through like a bit of a ho phase. Yeah. I was like, I just need this. Like, this is just like the most temporarily nourishing thing
并在这样一个非常大的伤口上贴一个临时的创可贴，这个伤口不仅会影响我的约会生活，还会影响到生活的方方面面。这绝对是我发现的问题。然后我经历了，我记得在我大二的时候，我经历了一段比较放纵的时期。是的。当时我想，我就是需要这个。这就像是最具短期滋养的事情
I could find. It was like, it was like junk food. I was like, oh, yeah. It feels so good and like, yum, like, this is all I've ever wanted. And then like, you wake up the next day and you're like, oh, I feel so. I feel terrible.
我能找到的。这就像，这就像垃圾食品。我想，哦，是的。感觉太棒了，太美味了，这就是我一直想要的。然后第二天醒来，你会觉得，哦，我感觉太差了。我感觉糟透了。
And like, that insecurity is still there, especially when it's like, it doesn't just become about whether they find you attractive, it's about whether they can love you. And then they don't love you. and then that's an even bigger insecurity. Yeah, that makes a film more. Like, yeah, sure, I'm like, I'm fuckable and I'm attractive,
而且那种不安全感依然存在，特别是当这不仅仅关乎他们是否觉得你有吸引力，而是关乎他们是否能爱你的时候。然后他们不爱你。接着这就成了更深的不安全感。是的，这让人感觉更……没错，当然，我觉得，我有吸引力，我也很迷人，
but am I lovable? Yeah. No? Like, you don't feel that way. And then you end up in situation chips, which is, I think, my bread and butter. Honestly, I've been in, like, four in the past. Yeah.
但我招人喜欢吗？是的。不对吧？你不会那样觉得。然后你就会陷入“友达以上，恋人未满”的暧昧关系中，我觉得这是我的家常便饭。说实话，我过去经历过大约四次。是的。
Year and a half. But I'm getting better at them now. Yeah. The last one I was like, he was like, I don't really want anything and I was like, great, see you later. Good for you. I was like, I was like not doing this again.
在过去的一年半里。但我现在在这方面处理得越来越好了。是的。上一次的时候，我说，他当时说，我其实什么都不想要，然后我说，太好了，再见。真为你高兴。我说，我再也不会这样做了。
And then it actually was really great because after like a couple weeks I had that realization where I was like, whoa, like, this man really didn't put in any effort. He was actually not that nice to me. He like doesn't really do anything with his life. Like I would be like, tell me like, remember I asked him on one of our first date?
然后事实证明这真的很棒，因为大约几周后我突然意识到，哇，这个男人真的没有付出任何努力。他其实对我也不是很好。他生活里也无所事事。比如我会问他，记得我在我们第一次约会时问过他吗？
So I was like, what's the thing you're most passionate about? Yeah. And he couldn't answer the question. Mm-hmm. and he was like my family and I was like yeah everyone's passionate about their family like it's called love yeah like like
当时我问，你最热衷的事情是什么？是的。而他回答不上来。嗯。然后他说我的家人，我说，是的，每个人都对自己的家人充满热情，这叫爱，对吧，就像
I was like and I was like oh you know he's still finding himself and then like cut to like five weeks later and I was like oh my gosh that should have given me that should have been the biggest indicator okay so I really want to talk about what we've learned
我说，然后我说，哦，你知道他在寻找自我。然后画面一转，大概五周后，我心想，天哪，我早该看出来的，那本该是最明显的信号。好吧，我真的很想谈谈我们学到了什么
we've already talked about that a little bit but what are we bringing into our dating lives in 2023 what are our non-negotiables didn't you make that you made a list this year, didn't you for your... I made a list, can I read it? Yeah. So these are my, these are my expectations and dating boundaries for 2022.
我们之前已经稍微聊过这个了，但我们在2023年的约会生活中会带入什么，我们的底线是什么？你不是做过吗？你今年列了个清单，不是吗，为了你的……我列了个清单，我能读一下吗？好的。所以这些是我的，这些是我的2022年约会期望和底线。
I think they might change this year, but the first one was, I'm looking for a relationship. That was something I realized. I think I always thought that I was like the hookup, one night stand, situation ship girly, and like I could just have heaps of casual sex and I'd be happy. And then I was like, actually, no,
我想今年它们可能会改变，但第一点是，我在寻找一段恋爱关系。这是我意识到的一点。我想我以前总是觉得自己是个喜欢随便玩玩、一夜情、暧昧关系的女孩，觉得我可以享受大把的随性性爱，并且会感到快乐。然后我发现，其实并不是，
I would like to be loved and cared for and supported. So I guess set your intention. like know what you're looking for, know what you want. Yeah, I feel like that's the first. Or even what you don't want. What I don't want. Yeah, yeah.
我是希望能被爱、被关心、被支持的。所以我想说，设定你的意图。知道自己在找什么，知道自己想要什么。是的，我觉得这是第一步。甚至知道你不要什么。我不要什么。是的，是的。
Which might be, you know, one night's dance, casual sex, whatever it is. Here's the thing, like, I'm still up for that, but like, I'm looking for a relationship. So I think if it's someone that I could seriously see myself dating and they don't want to date me, I've learned pretty, I've learned now through trial and error, like we talked about. Yeah. To cut that off, like as soon as possible, so no one gets hurt. Yeah. I also said, I will only go on five casual dates before I know what they want. It used to be like three, but I was like, sometimes you really do just want to get to know the person and like have a bit of like almost a friendship there or like have enough knowledge before knowing what they want.
可能是，你知道的，一夜情、随性性爱，不管是什么。事情是这样的，我还是可以接受那些，但我是在寻找一段恋爱关系。所以如果对方是我认真觉得自己可以与之约会，但他们却不想跟我约会的人，通过试错，我学到了相当多，就像我们讨论过的那样。是的。要尽早切断这种关系，以免有人受伤。是的。我还说过，在弄清楚对方想要什么之前，我最多只会进行五次随意的约会。以前大概是三次，但我觉得，有时你确实需要去了解对方，并在某种程度上建立一点类似友谊的关系，或者在知道他们想要什么之前掌握足够的信息。
If they're looking for something casual that is not for me, so I will break things off, which I did with that guy that I was saying, I think things ended in like October. I was like, nah, not going to work. This next one I think is really important. They need to message me to make plans. if I made the last plan I expect them to make the next and I will not compromise if they want to see me
如果他们在寻找随便的关系，那可不适合我，所以我就会结束关系，就像我之前提到的那个男生那样，我觉得我们在十月份左右结束了。当时我就想，算了，行不通的。接下来的这一条我觉得非常重要。他们需要主动发信息来做计划。如果上次的计划是我定的，我希望下次由他们来定，而且我绝不妥协。如果他们想见我，
they will that one I broke because I think sometimes like I'm the busier normally the busier party like I work a full-time job I also run the show I also have so many other things
他们就会主动。这一条我打破过，因为我觉得有时，我是那个更忙的人，通常是更忙的一方——我有一份全职工作，我还经营着这个节目，我生活中还有很多其他事情
going on in my life friends other side hustles like sports family so normally I'm the busier person so it's sometimes up to me to be like to indicate when I'm free
要忙，比如朋友、其他副业、运动、家庭，所以通常我是那个更忙的人，所以有时得由我来表示我什么时候有空。
yeah but most of the time i'm like i will be like i'm free on friday would you like to do something and then i if i've like planned the last day i'm like you expect them yeah yeah um frequent communication i'm not going for like i don't know i'm not going like two weeks without talking to someone completely and then they even like a week and then they like pop up i'm like okay if you can go without thinking about me for that long then i'm not really that interested and i don't think it's like a great foundation for if you're someone like me he was looking for a relationship at this point in their life this one's kind of like a little bit spicy so if you're my mom and dad you don't have to listen to this or someone I work with please after four dates where sex is involved
是的，但大多数时候我会主动说，我周五有空，你想做点什么吗？然后如果上一次的约会是我计划的，我就会想，你会期待他们来……是的，是的。呃，频繁的沟通。我不会接受那种，我不知道，我不会接受那种两周完全不联系某人，然后他们甚至过了一个星期才突然冒泡的情况，我就想，好吧，如果你能那么长时间不想到我，那我其实没那么感兴趣，而且我觉得这对于像我这样在这个人生阶段寻求恋爱关系的人来说，并不是一个很好的基础。这一条有点辛辣，所以如果你们是我的爸爸妈妈，或者是我工作上的同事，请不要听这个。在经历了四次涉及性行为的约会之后，
I expect a non-sexual date yeah because I think I fall into I fell into the trap with I said his name with the guy from end of last year like we would have sex every single day and I was like yeah obviously really enjoy having sex with you and it's like great but also I feel kind of like you don't really see me and it made me feel like me feeling pretty icky. Would you add anything to that list? I guess you're not really I feel like your your non-negotiables might be a little bit different. Yeah and I think um I don't think I'm looking for a relationship anymore. Oh yeah especially after what I went through the last breakup that I had, it definitely changed the way I think about how I date.
我期待一次非性行为的约会。是的，因为我觉得我陷入了，我上次跟那个去年年底的男生在一起时就陷入了这个陷阱——我们每天都发生性行为，然后我想，是的，当然我很享受和你做爱，这很棒，但同时我也有点觉得你并没有真正看到我，这让我感觉很不舒服。你会给这个清单加上什么吗？我想你其实不会……我觉得你的底线可能会有点不同。是的，而且我觉得，嗯，我觉得我不再寻找恋爱关系了。哦，是的。特别是经历了上次的分手之后，这绝对改变了我对约会的看法。
And I felt really, really completely misled in that relationship. If I can even call it a relationship. I would. Yeah, I think I would too. But then again, in saying that, if I met the right person, I think I would make it work, even though I might not explicitly be looking for a relationship right now. I also have a lot of travel plans next year, and I'm not willing to compromise on that currently for anyone.
而且在那段关系中，我真的、真的、完全被误导了。如果那甚至能被称为一段关系的话。我会这么认为的。是的，我想我也会。但话又说回来话，如果我遇到了对的人，我想我会让它行得通，尽管我可能现在并没有明确在寻找恋爱关系。我明年也有很多旅行计划，目前我不愿意为了任何人在这方面妥协。
Because you go to New York. Yeah, and Vietnam. Vietnam and the UK? Maybe. No, I'm going to the UK. I want us to go to the UK together. I'll go to the UK with you. Oh my God.
因为你要去纽约。是的，还有越南。越南和英国？也许吧。不，我要去英国。我想让我们一起去英国。我跟你一起去英国。天哪。
When are you going? March. But I think that's also a really good point. When I set these non-negotiables and these things that I've learnt, it's to protect myself because I realize that if I'm not explicit with myself and I don't compare the behaviour of someone I'm seriously interested in with this stuff, it can be quite detrimental and I can often get wrapped up I think you and I one thing we really have in common we are both incredibly sentimental romantic people yeah completely I think it's because we're both
你什么时候去？三月。但我觉得这也是个非常好的观点。当我设定这些底线以及我所学到的东西时，是为了保护我自己，因为我意识到，如果我对不够明确，并且不把我有意认真发展的人的行为与这些标准进行对比，那可能会相当有害，而且我经常会陷入其中。我觉得你和我有一个共同点，我们都是极其多愁善感、浪漫的人。是的，完全是。我想这是因为我们两个
quite creative as well so we want to we see the beauty and the love in so many places where I think other people don't yeah I feel like you're very like susceptible to to love I think I'm I just I'm so willing to believe like that this person wants to give me everything I think I am a romantic. Oh my God, absolutely. Romantic. Romantist? I'm a romantic.
也都很有创造力，所以我们能在许多别人看不到的地方看到美和爱。是的，我觉得你非常容易坠入爱河。我觉得我只是，我太愿意去相信这个人想给我一切了，我觉得我是一个浪漫主义者。天哪，绝对是的。浪漫主义者。浪漫的人？我是一个浪漫的人。
I'm a hopeless romantic. I love love. I love receiving love. I just want to give love to everyone. And so when someone wants to give me love, of course I'm going to accept it. Why would somebody lie about that? I do not know. Why would somebody lie about that?
我是个无可救药的浪漫主义者。我热爱爱。我喜欢接受爱。我只想把爱给每一个人。所以当有人想要给我爱时，我当然会接受。为什么有人会对此说谎呢？我不知道。为什么有人会对此说谎呢？
I don't know. If you can answer that for us, I feel like we would give you a sizable check. A lot of money. I can guess. I think it's, well, I think it stems from a deep insecurity within them. You know, they probably think they don't, you know, don't deserve love or don't have the capacity to be loved truly for who they are. So they love bomb vulnerable, beautiful people like us to make us, well, to feel closer to us
我不知道。如果你能为我们解答这个问题，我觉得我们可以给你开一张大额支票。很多钱。我能猜到。我认为，嗯，我认为这源于他们内心深处的不安全感。你知道，他们可能觉得自己不，你知道，不配得到爱，或者没有能力去真正被爱本来的样子。所以他们用爱轰炸脆弱、美丽的人，让我们，嗯，感觉离他们更近
and to then make us. To get that connection. Yeah, yeah. I also think it's because they don't know what they want. Yeah. And also, they don't. They don't. And then like the start of a relationship is like always the fun part, right?
从而让我们。建立那种连接。是的，是的。我也觉得是因为他们不知道自己想要什么。是的。而且，他们不知道。然后一段关系的开始总是最有趣的部分，对吧？
It's super exciting. And then they often don't realize that love and commitment takes more than just fun things and compliments and sex and gifts. Yeah. Like it actually takes vulnerability and honesty. Yeah. And often they're super on board for that first chapter. Yeah.
超级令人兴奋。然后他们经常没有意识到，爱和承诺需要的不仅仅是有趣的事情、赞美、性爱和礼物。是的。这其实需要脆弱和诚实。是的。而且通常他们对第一章非常支持。是的。
Where it's just like super fun and there's no responsibility. And it's like it's just getting to know someone. And then you get to that next stage where it actually requires you to have some kind of awareness of your emotional needs and their needs of others and they're like oh she's like I'm out like I can't do that how would you differentiate because I know every relationship is different and people yeah people always act differently when they meet you know everyone is different how would you differentiate somebody love bombing you with somebody who truly has fallen in love with you very quickly and showing that intensity at the beginning of you dating them and it's and it's true and it's authentic
那时一切都超级有趣，没有任何责任。这就像只是在了解一个人。然后当你进入下一个阶段，这实际上需要你对自己的情感需求和对方的需求有一定的觉察时，他们就会想，哦，她像是在说，我退出，我做不到。你会如何区分——因为我知道每段关系都不同，人们，是的，人们在遇到不同的人时总是表现不同，每个人都是不同的——你如何区分一个人对你的“爱轰炸”和一个人真正非常快地爱上了你，并且在你们约会初期表现出那种强烈的情感，而且那是真实的、真诚的、纯粹的，他们对你没有任何（你知道的）任何消极的意图，也没有任何操纵你的欲望？你如何区分这些？我前几天其实一直在想这个。我觉得关键在于识别这种行为是因何而起的。所以，如果这是对你退缩的反应，或者是对他们可能做错了某事的反应，这就是爱轰炸。是的。
and it's raw and they have no you know no negative um intentions towards you or no desire to manipulate you. How do you differentiate that? I actually was thinking about this the other day. I think it's about identifying what it's in response to. So it's love bombing if it's in response to perhaps you pulling away or them having done something maybe a little bit wrong. Yeah.
或者类似于让你心烦意乱的事情。是的。或者像我所认为的那样，爱轰炸可以被视为一种操纵形式。这是利用爱，不是去强迫，而是以一种他们自己无法兑现的方式来吸引你。是的。所以如果他们试图赢得你的芳心，那就是爱轰炸。是的。
Or like it's something that's upset you. Yeah. Or like as I think it's a form, love bombing would be seen as a form of manipulation. It's the use of like love to not coerce but to attract you in a way that like they can't fulfill on their end. Yeah. So it's like if they're trying to win you over, that's love bombing. Yeah.
因为一个人，你不可能真正爱上一个人，除非这种爱是相互的。嗯。你知道我的意思吗？所以，是的，你可能会有单相思。但当你想到那个真正爱你的人时，那很可能是因为你也真正深爱着他们。并且你们双方都允许自己展现脆弱并建立连接。所以当他们在那种情况下向你表达爱时，并不是为了试图赢得你的芳心。
Because someone who, you cannot truly fall in love with someone unless it's reciprocated. Mm-hmm. Do you know what I mean? So it's like, yeah, you could have unrequited love. But when you think about that person who truly loves you, it's probably because you truly love them back. And you've both allowed yourselves to be vulnerable and to connect. So when they show you love in that situation, it's not like they're trying to win you over.
他们已经赢得你的芳心了。是的。他们这样做不是为了。应对他们做错了什么，他们这样做也不是为了近乎强迫你，他们这样做只是因为这是一种普遍的、严肃的深厚情感的表达，而爱轰炸是一种赢得你芳心并俘获你的方式，是的，把你拉拢进来，还有所有那些兴奋感。是的，是的。我老实说，请不要听我的建议——去做你自己的研究，因为我不知道，至少我是这么想的。这让我想起了，嗯
They've already won you over. Yeah. They're not doing it in. response to something that they've done wrong they're not doing it to kind of almost coerce you they're doing it because it's just this general this like serious like expression of a deep emotion whereas love bombing is a way of like winning you over and like capturing you yeah bringing you in and like all that excitement yeah yeah i honestly if you please don't take my advice like do your research because i don't know that's just what i think at least and i think that reminds me of um
当我看了《其实没那么喜欢你》的时候，是的，嗯，我想他们说过，他们是怎么说的，他们说，凡事都有例外，你知道的，总有一两个例外，有些人遇到某人，然后瞬间坠入爱河，那种感觉如此强烈、充满激情、美好，并且这种状态会持续好几年。但对大多数人来说，他们说我们是符合规律的。是的，所以它才叫规律。因为这是典型的。是的，我爷爷奶奶就是那些例外之一。天哪。我昨晚还跟他们一起出去吃晚饭。
when I watched he's just not that into you yeah and um I think they said what do they they said something like there is the exception you know like there's always that one or or two exceptions for people who you know meet someone and and instantly fall in love and it's so intense and passionate and beautiful and then it continues that way for years but for most of us what are they they say we are the rule yeah that's why it's called a rule yeah because it's typical yeah my grandparents are one of those exceptions. Oh my God. I went out for dinner with them last night.
他们太相爱了。他们大概90岁和80岁。大概87岁和80岁吧，我想。我爷爷还是会说，哦，宝贝，你今晚看起来真迷人。而且，会叫她宝贝，字面意义上会为她做任何事。现在不生产这样的男人了。
They are so in love. They're like 90 and 80. Like 87 and 80, I think. And my granddad's still like, oh, babe, you look lovely tonight. And, like, calls her babe and, like, we'll literally do anything for her. They don't make men like that anymore.
确实没有。他们当时在告诉我，我妈妈在告诉我，他们刚开始约定时，我奶奶刚刚经历了一场非常混乱的离婚。是的。虽然她不听这个，但我希望她不会介意我谈论这个。她和我真正的爷爷经历了一场非常混乱的离婚，
They don't. They were telling me, my mom was telling me, when they first started dating, my grandma had just come out of a really messy divorce. Yeah. She doesn't listen to this, but I hope she won't mind me talking about it. She came out of this really messy divorce with my actual grandfather,
我从未跟那个爷爷说过话。他真的很糟糕，然后她遇到了这个男人，我的爷爷——不是生物学上的爷爷，而是抚养我的爷爷。也就是说，他就是我的爷爷，虽然他不是我的血亲。但依然是，骨子里的家人。她遇到了他，而他简直把她迷住了。就像我们刚才谈到的，仅仅因为爱一个人而做事与爱轰炸之间的区别。他带她去旅行。
who I've never spoken to. And he was like really awful, and she met this man, my grandfather, and not my, my grandfather by nature, not by blood. Like, he is my grandfather, but he's not my blood relative. But still, like, family thrown through. And she met him, and he just, like, wowed her. Like what we were talking about, that distinction between just doing things because you love someone and love plumbing. He, like, took her on trips.
他给她买钻石。他从巴黎给她买皮草大衣。他聘请她加入他的摄影业务，让她负责一切。就像让她掌管一切一样。会听取她的商业建议。给她买房子，带她搬到澳大利亚。就像全套服务一样。是的。
He bought her, like, diamonds. He bought her fur coats from Paris. He, like, he hired her as part of his photography business and got her to run everything. Like, got her in charge of everything. Would take her business advice. Bought her a house, moved her to Australia. Like, the whole cabab. Yeah.
应有尽有。只要他想。他就会做到。我就想，而且字面意义上，现在依然深爱着她。是的。就像每年，都如此、如此深爱着她，觉得她就是最了不起的女性。然后我就想，靠。嗯。
Everything. If he wanted to. He would. And I was like, and literally, and is still in love with her. Yeah. Like, every year, like, is so, so in love with her and thinks that she is just the most amazing woman. And I was like, fuck. Mm-hmm.
我得回到1960年代什么的，去挑一个这样的男人。他太可爱了。这真的让人，但我现在觉得自己很幸运。你知道，你让我觉得，其实，我也有过那些榜样。比如我的父母也是，我想。他们还在一起。是的，他们还在一起。嗯。
I need to go back to whenever the 1960s and pick me up one of these guys. He's so lovely. It's honestly such a, but I feel very lucky now. You know, you've made me think that, like, I've actually, I've had those examples. And, like, my parents as well, I would say. They're still together. Yeah, they're still together. Mm-hmm.
我觉得他们挺相爱的。我不知道。我不想去想这个。但我的确有过那些榜样，看到人们相守相依并真正投入精力。是的。好吧，最后一个问题。你觉得到2023年底，你的爱情生活会是怎样的？
I'd say they're pretty in love. I don't know. I don't like to think about it. But I've had those examples of, like, people sticking around and really putting in the energy. Yeah. Yeah. Well, one final question. Where do you see your love life at the end of 2023?
这很难。这很难。而且，我觉得我的，你知道的，我爱情生活的背景在过去的一个月里发生了太大的变化。是的。以至于我正在重新思考一切。我看到你完全坠入爱河的样子。你觉得呢？哦，是的。
It's hard. It's hard. And, like, I feel like my, the, you know, context around my love life has changed so much in the last month. Yeah. That I'm rethinking everything. I see you fully in love. Do you reckon? Oh, yeah.
我知道你说你不是在寻找恋爱关系。我不觉得你在找，但作为你非常亲密的朋友，不管你接不接受，我觉得你本质上就是一个适合谈恋爱的女孩。我觉得，是的，我觉得在，你知道的，我觉得我也是。现在是的。
I know you say you're not looking for a relationship. I don't think you're looking, but as your very close friend, take it or later, I think you are someone who is a relationship girlie. I think, yeah, I think at the, you know, I think I am as well. Right now, yeah.
我觉得我确实只想把所有的爱都给一个人。是的，因为你太慷慨了。当你爱一个人时，你爱得那么深。在我这一生所有的经历中，你是我见过的最慷慨、最乐于付出的人之一。我想你确实想把这份爱给某人。是的。而且你身上有那么多爱可以付出。你看，你对那些甚至无法回报的人都付出了那么多，这太离谱了。
I think I do want to just give somebody all my love. Yeah, because you are so, so generous. When you love someone, you love them so deeply. You are one of the most generous giving people I have ever met in all my travels in my whole life. And I think you do want to give that to someone. Do, yeah. And you have so much of it to give. Like, the amount that you're giving people who can't even reciprocate is ridiculous.
想象一下当有人给予回报时。那将是一场大爆发。我觉得我是一个很好的女朋友。哦，太棒了。我会跟你约会。我也会跟你约会的。天哪。我们要不？
Like, imagine when someone is reciprocating. It's going to be an explosion. I'm such a good girlfriend, I think. Oh, freak yeah. I would date you. I would date you too. Damn. Should we?
恋人。永远。我看到自己处于一段恋爱关系中。我看到……说实话，我觉得我短期内不会进入一段恋爱关系。真的吗？噢天哪。我明年太忙了。
Lovers. Forever. I see being in a relationship. I see... Honestly, I don't think I'm getting into a relationship anytime soon. Really? Oh my gosh. Next year is so busy for me.
是的，你现在正和你的工作谈恋爱呢。是的，我入迷了。这太离谱了。不过没关系。我觉得这……事实上，我觉得这挺棒的。我知道。我有时确实会为此感到有点自我意识过剩。
Yeah, you are in a relationship with your work right now. Yeah, I'm obsessed. It's ridiculous. Which is okay. I think that's... In fact, I think that's great. I know. I do, like, feel a bit self-conscious about it sometimes.
比如，我不知道，朋友和家人经常会说，是的，你不能总是工作。但我太投入了。这就像是一件大事，其中之一……我喜欢做这个。对我来说这是一笔巨大的投资。我其实真的很在乎它，并且想每天都做。每时每刻，我都在想着它。那我怎么有时间把这分心给别人呢？
Like, I don't know, friends and family, often like, yeah, you need to not work all the time. And I'm just too, I'm too invested. Like, this is the big, like, one of... This is, I love doing this. It's such an investment to me. I just actually really care about it and want to do it every day. Every waking minute, I'm always thinking about it. So how can I have time to give that to someone else?
因为我觉得如果我要和某人约会，它会分走那些目前真正驱动我、滋养我灵魂的事物。所以那不会是我想要的。非常感谢你来参加节目，悉尼。谢谢。这真是一期有趣的节目。是的，我觉得非常宣泄。
Because I think if I was to be dating someone, it would take away from the things that really drive me at the moment and really fuel my soul. So it wouldn't be what I would want. Thank you so much for coming on, Sydney. Thank you. That was such a fun episode. Yeah, I felt really cathartic.
是的。和你聊天总是这样。是的，哦，和你聊天也总是这样。我太爱你啦。我也爱你。噢天哪。我也觉得这是一种回顾我们今年所学并将其带入新年的绝佳方式。
Yeah. It always is to talk to you. Yeah. Aw, it always is to talk to you as well. I love you so much. I love you too. Oh my gosh. I also just feel like it's such a great kind of way to reflect on what we've learned this year and bring it into the new year.
在结束之前还有什么最后的想法吗？约会是我生活中非常重要的一部分，而且非常有趣。但我觉得明年真的是时候专注于我自己了。而且我觉得，我也希望所有听众也花时间真正去爱自己，把明年奉献
Any final thoughts before we wrap up? Dating is such an important and such an important part of my life and it's so fun. But I think next year it's really time to focus on me. And I think, and I hope everyone listening also takes the time to really love themselves and dedicate next year. to yourself. Actually, there's this really good quote I saw. Do you mind if I read it to you? Yeah, of course. So it goes, if you spend your time chasing butterflies, they'll fly away. If you spend your time making a beautiful garden, the butterflies will come to you. And if they don't come, then you still have that garden. I love that quote. I think that's so beautiful.
给你自己。其实，我看到过一句很好的名言。你介意我读给你听吗？当然不介意。上面写着，如果你花时间去追逐蝴蝶，蝴蝶就会飞走。如果你花时间打造一座美丽的花园，蝴蝶就会飞向你。如果它们不来，那你也依然拥有那座花园。我很喜欢这句话。我觉得太美了。
That's so emblematic. Yeah, it's a great way to finish this episode. I think the one thing we haven't talked about much that is so important is that the relationship you cultivate with yourself, You know, we've talked a lot about dating, but that relationship is the most important one you will ever have in your entire life. Yeah. It's the only one that isn't going to disappear. It's not going to go away. It is essential that you spend time focused on what you mean to yourself, how you love yourself, what you like to do and those close relationships that really bring you joy. So the garden, your own garden, I guess.
太有象征意义了。是的，这是结束本期节目的一种绝佳方式。我觉得我们还没有怎么谈过、但又极其重要的一点是，你与自己的关系——你知道，我们聊了很多关于约会的内容，但与自己的关系才是你一生中最重要的关系。是的。这是唯一不会消失的关系。它不会走开。花时间关注你对自己的意义、你如何爱自己、你喜欢做什么以及那些真正给你带来快乐的亲密关系，是至关重要的。所以，那座花园，你自己的花园，我想是这样的。
One other thing before we go that we want to talk about is that we have. some merchandise coming out. Are you excited? I'm so excited for it. I am as well. We're doing a tow bag and a hoodie. It's going to be an exclusive launch and yeah, Sydney is actually designing both of them. Thank you for asking me to design it.
在我们离开之前，还有一件事想谈谈，那就是我们要推出一些周边商品。你兴奋吗？我太兴奋了。我也是。我们正在做一款托特包和一个连帽衫。这将是一个独家发布，而且，是的，悉尼实际上设计了这两款产品。谢谢你邀请我设计。
Oh, I literally, there's no one else I would have to do it. Of course. I trust you so much and I love what you do. So I was like, it's such an amazing thing that we can do together. And we were released some early images and the link. to purchase on the podcast Instagram at that psychology podcast. If you want to follow Sydney as well at Sid Farray, F-A-R-E-Y. Yeah, S-Y-D-F-A-R-E-Y.
哦，我真的，没有其他人比我更合适了。当然。我非常信任你，我也喜欢你的作品。所以我当时就觉得，这是我们可以一起做的最棒的事情。我们将在播客Instagram账号@thatpsychologypodcast上发布一些早期图片和购买链接。如果你也想关注悉尼，可以关注@Sid Farray，F-A-R-E-Y。是的，S-Y-D-F-A-R-E-Y。
Sid Ferry, F-R-E-Y. F-A-F-R-E-Y. And we'll release some pictures. If you want to get your hands on some merchandise to support the podcast to support Sydney's amazing artwork and amazing work as an artist, We would be very appreciative. And also it's just going to be really sick. Yeah.
Sid Ferry，F-R-E-Y。F-A-F-R-E-Y。我们会发布一些图片。如果你想买到这些周边来支持播客，支持悉尼作为艺术家的惊艳画作和出色工作，我们会非常感激。而且这也真的会非常酷。是的。
Yeah, it'll be really... So pretty. Yeah. I can't wait to wear it. Oh, me too. It will be released in the next two months. So make sure you're following along to get your hands on that. I'm so excited.
是的，真的会……太漂亮了。是的。我迫不及待想穿上它了。哦，我也是。它将在未来两个月内发布。所以请务必保持关注，以便买到它们。我太兴奋了。
It's one of the big things I wanted to do for 2023. And it's great being able to do it with a close friend. So thank you again for coming on. Thank you so much for letting me come on. Yeah, one of my favorite episodes. I love talking to my friends on the show. Oh. If you enjoyed this episode, if you enjoy the podcast, please make sure to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now.
这是我为2023年想做的大事之一。能和一个亲密的朋友一起完成这件事情真的很棒。所以再次感谢你来参加节目。非常感谢你让我来。是的，我最喜欢的节目之一。我喜欢在节目中和我的朋友聊天。哦。如果你喜欢这一期节目，如果你喜欢这个播客，请务必在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听的任何平台上留下五星好评。
If you feel called to do so, it really helps the show grow and reach new audiences. And make sure you are following our Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. Like I said, it's where you will hear the first about merchandise. We also often do polls where you can decide what episodes are coming out in the week. that follows. I let my listeners decide what I record. So if you want to be involved in the community, please feel free to follow us over there. And thank you so much for listening. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations
如果你愿意的话，这真的能帮助节目成长并触达新的受众。请务必关注我们的Instagram账号：@That Psychology Podcast。就像我说的，你将在那里第一时间听到关于周边的消息。我们还经常发起投票，你可以决定接下来一周要播出什么主题的节目。我让听众来决定我录制什么。所以如果你想参与到这个社区中，请随时关注我们的账号。非常感谢大家的收听。嘿，大家好，你们好！欢迎收听《艰难学会》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间专门探讨黑男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话
that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实并不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一身盔甲？这向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在IHeart电台应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学会》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神坚韧、体能和韧性的科学。经历一些艰难险阻，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
收听《2%》。即TWO.%，在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约定时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J.
收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回看》（Look Back at it）播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. Before it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。在每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。在那之前，那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHeart电台应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证真人。本集节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。